how much of fraud do you think went into
this election
how much fraud you know i i think that
there are there is a
chance that there is some fraud that's
going on was it the fraud that got
j.f kennedy john f kennedy into office
no i mean you didn't have
two entire states uh where there were
numerous hundreds of thousands of dead
people voting
so yes there might have been a tiny bit
of fraud i think
and there's likely fraud in every single
election and they'll be fraud in the
2022 midterms
and that's just a part of life but again
it was great weather
nationwide you had the highest turnout
you had 66.9
turnout in this election you have to go
back to the year 1900
that's the last time we had this higher
voter 20 years
1900 the presidential election
so
percentage-wise yes what was the
percentage 73.2
turnout in 1966.9 percent turnout in
and because again i mean weather is a
you know if you've got a foot of snow on
the ground in the midwest
you're not going to have that many
people voting it was unusual
you brought up it was a nice weather day
it was a nice weather day
nationwide and you had lots of people
voting
on election day as well and when you
listen to the states
whether it's the attorney general of
michigan or wisconsin they're like it
was just a normal day we had
just a few snafu's here and there you
had polls open late in atlanta
they compensated by that for staying
open an hour late
so uh it was a very smooth smoothly run
uh election day by the way if you're
watching this and if you think there was
voter fraud
press thumbs up push thumbs up if you
think there wasn't
any voter fraud to the point where it
could influence the entire election put
thumbs down so either thumbs up for yes
there was voter fraud thumbs down
there wasn't did you see the project
veritas video yesterday with michigan
i did not okay so do you know it came
out very late it came out like
i don't know what time but we came out
late do you know how many views it got
in the first seven
hours on twitter have you seen it
million views how many views you think
got on twitter
on twitter twitter i don't know a couple
hundred thousand seven million i was
going to say
seven hours can you pull up the video i
just want you to see what happens here
and you know for me i can tell the
difference between an act and when you
listen to the voice you don't hear
somebody that's acting
listen to this guy on how he speaks and
who he is that's two minutes
go ahead i work in the traverse city
post office more specifically the
barlow bridge your boss told you and
your colleagues something that shocked
you this morning what was it
we were issued a directive this morning
to
collect any ballots we find in mailboxes
collection boxes just outgoing mail in
general
separate them at the end of the day so
that they could uh hand stamp them with
the
previous day's date today is november
4th
for clarification who is your boss adam
what is this type of jonathan would be a
direct
as of right now he is the opening
supervisor for the barlow branch
post office so i did mrs
carrier down in another office said they
watched the postmaster doing it
so you know what they're saying there
were just a typical day it would be
clerks
doing it up at the distribution center
so 8 p.m election day november 3rd
uh the court of appeals uh ruled ballots
have to be received by that time
and and what were you told they're
suffering today so they can mark them on
yesterday's day
and send them to the express system this
appears to be an attempt to circumvent
michigan law and allow late votes
and uh you said there was a hamper where
letter carriers were supposed to leave
their ballots
where are the ballots now they were
putting them into express bags
to go to the distribution center in
regards to a
hamper there's a standard hamper that
all letter now is supposed to go to and
they have a tub next to it that we were
supposed to
put in the ballots collected
[Music]
[Laughter]
to other postal workers who see things
like this
how are we supposed to have any
integrity in this country
are you afraid of retaliation against
you uh i've had whistleblower policies
backfire on me in the past
so yes we'll have to reach out to
jonathan clark for comment
is this jonathan yes hey i'm a reporter
with project veritas and james o'keefe
here
and i have a i have information that you
guys have been stamping
ballots with the previous date november
3rd
you just have to sign me you just take
up the phone on me
what's your reaction to that danielle um
i this type of
un unsubstantiated the sources unknown
could have come from anybody yeah but
why did a guy hang up
who's saying on the phone for that no i
don't know you but i'm about to call you
right away and basically accuse you how
many crazies do you think have called
that person
all day long but here's a question for
you so both of you are saying this is
nothing that's not what i said
is that what you're saying i don't know
no no i'm not saying it's nothing i'm
saying
it is potentially something that could
be investigated
yeah but and should be investigated
so investigate it yeah so we put the
election on hold
and we investigate this to see if
there's anything to it before we
announce the president
i don't think the entire issue is going
on hold because that's mission
120 000 ballots in michigan were dropped
and in wisconsin there were trump votes
played the other thing on what happened
in california here watch this one in
california
i mean you're seeing this stuff all over
the place and to me make the video in a
way
is there anything you can do to the
video kai or no
uh i wanna i wanna show this video see
if you can change the video in the
format
um man you gotta find a video and maybe
copy paste it but go ahead you were
gonna say something
a couple different things obviously
there's people out there who are just
fraudulent fraudulent fraudulent
fraudulent fraudulent i'm not there
i'm not going to i'm not into a
fraudulent fraudulent campaign you know
what camp i'm in
what's that i'm in the count it once
count it twice
count it three times bring it to the
supreme court there's no chance i want
biden winning this election and having
four years of
he stole it it's it's all illegal i want
it to be
triple checked i'm on the same page
triple checked and if it comes out that
the
the vote calculations are totally off
and totally lost you lost just man up he
lost
there's no chance that i want four years
of of more chaos in this country
so watch this i wanted to be triple
checking already called the state
because these are male legoland ballots
are there a ton in there yeah
all right are you collecting from a lot
of places by the way this is in
california yeah this guy
but they called in very early california
you think california is flipping but
all right and let me just ask you one
thing where do you guys take them
election center that's it watch what
happens when she gets close to the
government building
okay thank you
thank you are there a lot more in there
watch what he says get back it's six
feet
thank you guys i just want to see
because they called our state so quickly
i know i
am you don't have a you don't have a
mask either oh yeah sorry
are they allowed to do that are they
allowed to do that so so look
the the people the folks who are upset
saying there's voter fraud
i want to look at history of voter fraud
just to kind of see what
voter fraud happened last night and this
morning because i'm actually curious now
for voter fraud right
so do you know how elections were up
until 1804 do you know how we chose
presidents and vice presidents up until
you had duels and you would shoot your
opponent yeah well that was that was
actually not a bad setup right but do
you actually know how they did it like i
didn't know i didn't know this danielle
did you know how they did it up until
no i wasn't around then so so when you
and i ran if you got two million i got
one million nine
you become the president i become the
vice president awesome oh yes
yes yes pretty intense i mean you heard
him who is your number two
you lose your number two first or less
bite would become president unless
you're saying trump will because
so biden would have four more years of
ribbon cutting yeah so that's that but
just think about it
that's how would you imagine the fact
that i my brain when my mind went there
dude thinking what if that actually was
the case
i love it so that's up until 1804. now
in 1803 there was something called
cooping
are you familiar with cooping i know
about riding a cougar you know when you
know what coupe
you know what cooping was called here's
what cooping was cooping back in the
days and this went until 1920 by the way
they stopped
it went up until al capone cooping was
they would find people in the streets
they would pull you off they would get
you drunk they would give you drugs they
would disguise you to go vote multiple
times for different people
and by the way craziest story edgar
allan poe
died outside of a voting poll on
election day
and they say he was one of the folks
that was
used for cooping so the famous author so
so now so then
so then you continue you continue up
until 1890 do you know up until 1890 how
they did election
you had to publicly say who you voted
for okay so you
exactly so you would you asked her a
question yesterday you were going would
you be willing to tell us
but up until up until 1890 you would say
i'm voting for trump i'm voting for
biden and everybody
would love no no up until 1890. okay
so then they said listen this is a
little too out of control it's going to
piss people off nobody can keep it a
secret so some people actually didn't
want to come out and vote
because they said i'd rather not vote
than tell people
who i'm voting for they say we got to
change it
so then eventually around 1890 or so
they changed it to a secret ballot and
secret ballot was a system that they
took from australia that's how australia
did it for longest time
so this led to the largest change
because now you could go and it was
specific rules and guidelines they put
up it was in an indoor space in public
buildings run by government officials
there will be a single ballot to produce
by states the ballot would obtain
contain the names of the candidates with
an option to also write in
the ballot will be completed in total
privacy that's what happened there now
from that time even with secret ballots
fraudsters still showed up because of
impersonation at the polls
false registration duplicate voting
fraudulent absentee votes buying votes
illegal assistant at the post
ineligible voting altering vote count
ballot petition fraud
and since 1980 there's been a thousand
seventy one
instances of voter fraud even even in
one say that last part again please
1071 instances of voter fraud
since 1980 so in the last 40 years
which is a small number there's a very
small number 1071.
by the way the chances of there being a
voter i'll give you the percent i'm
actually going to give you guys some
some content here the chances of voter
fraud
is between point zero zero zero
four zeros four percent up to point
zero zero so 0.00004
2.0009 so essentially
less than less than less than less than
one percent less than less than less
than one percent yes but there's been
1071 cases
of voter fraud and i think the biggest
concern people have right now
do you know how many votes bush beat
gore buy
in in two do you know how many votes
like a couple thousand votes in florida
maybe even a couple hundred something
i don't think it was a couple hundred
thousand i think it was no no a couple
hundred yeah it was five thirty nine
yeah rejection in a state that florida
not 539 million voters
539 okay voters
guys so right now as
as of 99 of votes having been counted to
that
because god knows it's going to be
running around on my twitter feed later
on
right now biden has a 241 000 count
lead over trump in the state of michigan
yeah
a quarter million almost yeah so i'm
that's a massive lead but by the way
even if
that's a mess even if the whistleblower
is correct and there was an instance
if you will and he did his civic duty
and
rightly so and and blew the whistle even
if that's the case
241 000 is a plenty big margin
right you you have to do a recount
automatically if your margin is in
between one percent
it's not you could drive a golf cart
through it so it's you're right it's not
wisconsin is but michigan is a different
story and danielle let me say one thing
thank you for bringing that up because
i actually found out how you know the
total the guy was like armored the
travers sugar
barlow branch you know the total
population of traverse city
fifteen thousand total population
yeah in traverse city michigan i've been
there it's upstate michigan
yeah but he's on the barlow branch so
meaning he's in one post office
in a 15 000 person city so let's just
say that there was some shady stuff
let's say that guy was
absolutely right shady as hell maybe
there's a couple hundred votes
maybe a couple thousand maybe you just
said there's only been a thousand
instances of voter fraud in 40 freaking
years so let's say that guy was sure to
as well
what are we talking about a couple
hundred votes but you have to know that
i mean for you have to know
there is a much bigger chance to do
voter fraud with mail-in ballots
much bigger chance to the voter fraud
with mailing ballots of course if you
don't agree with that you're naive
yourself
there's a much to say a hundred and
sixty million
people voted biden got more votes than
by
than uh obama are you saying he's a
better candidate than obama i mean it's
not even
you biting the campaign and he got more
than more than uh
uh or obama did so the mainland ballots
changed the game
you